[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and
very exciting to be talking about
revolutionising molecular diagnostics we
have Franco Koichi joining us on the
show pillo Franco hello thank you so
much for coming on thank you for
inviting me we're very excited for this
and we also have dr. Lewis and that's go
join us on the show as well hello thank
you thank you for coming on again we
just crushed it at our event identifying
and correcting perverse incentives that
was a super fun event I'm happy you were
in attendance that's actually where we
met yeah and because we had interviewed
the Indy bio batch 8 class but we didn't
get to you and so now it's getting to
happen we're very excited to talk about
the Seleucid donor Frank was backings
co-founder and CEO of Casper biotech
which is a CRISPR based company powering
the next generation of Diagnostics you
can find the link in the bio that CAS PR
dot bio as well as all of his LinkedIn
Twitter Instagram profiles as well as
the profile to bio captivate ear
Biosciences and Lewis's Twitter as well
so Franklin let's start things off with
one of our favorite questions to ask our
guests what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world well that's
that's a good question I think I mean
I'm excited for the direction of our
world I'm I'm I'm young I'm 24 years old
so I try to measure like every 10 years
to try to go back 10 years to see where
I was when I was 14 and when I was 4
years old I think that I changed a lot
obviously because I grew up I went
through adolescence a lot of things but
also how I saw the world changed in
those 20 24 years I'm super super
excited for the next 10 20 and 50 years
so I think there's there's a lot of
things happening it's everything is it's
becoming exponential in terms of biology
technology biotech and and in that sense
I'm very excited for for what is to come
for this world and what do you think so
core
principal or ethic that we need to all
embody to make sure we prosper really
well moving forward hmm
I mean I always myself I always try to
to be like I'm real and things like very
curious about stuff and and and
curiosity has its good aspect and I also
it's it's it's negative aspect it's
always important to embrace like healthy
curiosity and to try to to to to remain
by gender about things that are going on
but but obviously take into account the
the other and the people that surround
us in those decisions that we make as a
daily basis and then what about your
journey you're born in Buenos Aires in
Argentina and then you as a kid growing
up how did you get interested in biotech
who were you growing up tell us about it
the truth is as a kid I was never
interested about biotech I mean that I
wasn't good particularly good at science
or biology or chemistry whatever in
school I kind of got into biotech at at
a relatively later stage so I studied I
studied economics with a specialization
in health care so that was when I
started to get the feel about healthcare
and diagnostics and therapeutics and and
in that sense that was my first step
into what today is about this my biotech
profile and what was it like growing up
in Buenos Aires in Argentina what is
that like compared to you know the
Silicon Valley culture now I mean I I
love my country that Argentina Buenos
ideas obviously us being a developing
country we have our economic risks and
our thermals socio-economic terms but in
terms of the quality of life and and the
opportunities which I had given the
the what what my pal my parents my
parents gave to me I I was very lucky in
that sense and and I was able to enjoy a
lot of the country and take risks at a
very young age that being a luxury and
something that they very I am very very
grateful but to which a lot of people
within the country and within the world
don't don't have that luxury of being
capable of taking risks and in that
sense I feel like and I want to give
back to to the world in terms of what we
develop in Casper as technology and I
mean our possibilities and before we get
there are also on a short case how cool
it is that when you're studying
economics at the University of San
Andreas yes Dena that you founded and oh
yes there's a b2b last mile logistics
solution and that was acquired and you
founded that when you were 21 yeah
that's right very bad I was in first
second year of college and and OWASA
yeah startup which saw the the last mile
logistics for for e-commerce with within
the city and the country we I grew up
from a team of just myself and doing the
first that we were using in my own bike
to a team of 1012 people and in that
sense it was a very good experience for
me showing what it was like to execute
on a start-up from leveraging the the
right team the the right investors the
right advisors towards fulfilling on
that vision and executing and then also
that you participate in two really cool
immersion programs one of them the US
Department state young leaders
initiative which brought 250
entrepreneurs from Latin America and the
Caribbean for a one month immersion
program in the US and then also the
Westerwelle Foundation which brought 25
entrepreneur emerging countries to come
to Germany to connect with the European
hmm starving future I thought when
you're teaching Luis and I about this
before the show started I was like this
is very cool it's a great way to bring
people together from around the plan
but it's also like we want to make sure
that sometimes that you guys are also
bringing your brilliance to home as well
to help yeah yeah III think they were
two very different but great experiences
connecting with other 249 entrepreneurs
from Latin America and the Caribbean
here in the u.s. in in a fully immersive
program and and connecting with relevant
players within the industry for each of
those startups or each of those
intrapreneurs was was a great personal
experience and in that sense it was a
program which was fully funded by the US
Department of State and and and it was
an important decision to make from from
that side and and in my case it did
really nicely in terms of the
opportunities which arise from that
experience the Western world was was was
a similar program focusing on developing
countries from all over the world so
bringing entrepreneurs 25 entrepreneurs
from all over the world to to Germany
for a one-week program and there we we
also got to to connect with a lot of
relevant people within the startup
ecosystem of Europe and those are
connections which I I still have at a
personal level one or two years after I
love that that's the slow but sure we're
coming together as a planet through
programs yeah yeah yeah I'm not finding
of those programs I love that yeah and
then all right now for also for for
those that that that are wondering you
know okay this is interesting you know
Luis is on the show and this is because
a Luis is going to get into some of the
deeper biotech stuff and I'm gonna act
as the child here so okay now let's do
let's jump into a castro biotech so what
is this how did this come up what was
the story behind it teachers about it of
course
so I started Kaspar biotech with my
micro funding team of three scientists
that that belong to to the equivalent of
the NIH in Argentina which which will be
Kony set and they were kind of the
pioneer group for CRISPR with
in argentina and latin america leading
in seminars and presentations so they
were very present within within the
region and and they were using CRISPR
for all kinds of interesting things such
as really cellular reprogramming
epigenetics mostly working with with
class 9 and I came upon them and crisper
and and that first instance was
fascinated about the technology and also
about this this great group of people
that were really open to sharing their
insights and their experience with
CRISPR that they had been working on for
more than five or six years together two
of them being PhDs in CRISPR as a group
and and from from not only their
willingness to share their experience
but also their their willingness to to
work together and to do something which
in argentina's kind of considered crazy
which is jumping from the academia from
from basic research to having or
executing a start-up and making the
technology that they've been researching
about something with with a concrete
application so that was kind of the head
start of wanting to do something
together I had no idea no background on
CRISPR biotech I had some minor
background on healthcare and in that
sense for me was a learning from from
the ground up of everything CRISPR
related and it was a great experience
because I'd love to to be challenged and
to face new information every day but it
was difficult obviously and in that
sense we we got together we we saw about
the possibilities that of water rised
from from this technology and the
potential of executing that from
Argentina to the world in general and
within the CRISPR diagnostic space which
was kind of just getting published with
with with some recent papers from from
both the UC Berkeley group and
embroidering Institute was that we found
a very interesting solution that was
much needed within the region
within the world obviously for having
better more accessible faster
Diagnostics
and in that sense we we focused on and
we said okay there's something here that
we can do we can execute and we can do
well and decided to co-found Kasper
biotech and we're lucky enough to to be
invested by by one of like an investment
group which comes from from the main
pharma companies from from Argentina
cool
so there we raced our first proceed
round and that was about December of
last year and when we were just about to
get started in Argentina we got
connected to in the bio which told us
hey don't start in Argentina come here
to the u.s. to San Francisco and start
here directly so in January February we
we moved here we ordered our first
reagents here - - in the bio and the
promise or the premise of in the bio was
you'll move ten times faster and looking
back to it we we really moved at least
10 times faster I mean we really felt
that we each week we were moving at a
pace in which we we we couldn't
previously imagined and then maybe I can
get back to - why was it that that we
were able to to move so fast with
compared with a comparison to what we
might be have been able to achieve in
the six months in in Buenos Aires but
for us it was the best decision we were
possibly capable of doing and yeah being
here in San Francisco being in the bio
West was a game changer decision and now
walk us through yeah walk us through
what what's the problem in healthcare
that you saw and then what does Kaspar
do - yeah to address it yeah so so the
basic problem that that we saw with in
healthcare is diagnostics and
diagnostics has a lot of variables which
account to that problem and those are I
mean there's some components at a
general level and some components which
are region specific so so there
which part of the world you you you see
it from oh and that's actually the next
I think the next slide shows the one of
the this is a climate specifically they
that you can get a lot of insights from
because yeah things live in these yeah
I'm dreamin about that's the crisper
side to do what we see but in terms of
of the Diagnostics problem the variables
the important variables are speed for
result the accessibility component in
terms of both the cost and bid for
diagnostic yeah okay accessibility in
terms of cost and most importantly in
terms of work can we diagnose today
which is highly limited to in hospital
or in lab diagnosis and the
possibilities which arise from a
technology such as CRISPR cause speed
and location yeah what are we diagnosing
I mean today what I mean today were
diagnosing for for a lot of things in
Casper were diagnosing using CRISPR
which obviously when people hear and
know about CRISPR they mostly associated
to gene editing and that was kind of the
first described utility of of CRISPR and
in that sense it's a technology that
within that field is said to change the
world for all of us the the Diagnostics
activity of CRISPR or its utility comes
from not cast 9 as the key enzyme but
rather another enzyme within the CRISPR
world that was discovered some some
years ago by the scientific community
which are casting enzymes which have
collateral activity so I'd like to yeah
casts enzymes of quarrel with color
activity so they're very similar in some
traits with with cast 9 in the sense
that they have this very specific I mean
you configure them to a guide RNA you
have the same configuration towards a
specific DNA sequence or RNA sequence
amino acid sequence that you want to
detect or to to identify and in the case
of cast 9 for
for genetic the the Casa enzyme we'll
find it
cut it edit and that's like the gene
editing capability for Diagnostics the
caste and sang will will also Caswell
will also find its target sequence if
its person cut it and after doing that
first cut it it will kind of coquetry
and then we can show animation studio ok
so we'll show the next side round so
this is the cast 12 enzyme yeah most
people are familiar with the cast 9 yeah
enzyme yeah ok
and so this class of casts enzymes have
different applications the cast 9 makes
identifies the sequence makes an edit
and then inserts yeah that's right new
DNA hmm but cast 12 identify cuts and
then goes Gracie goes crazy basically ok
and we have that video but quickly what
teach us about this cat what is this
cast family what yeah so so the premise
is Casa enzymes are present within
nature itself in a defense system for
bacteria and archaea against viruses so
so that's how CRISPR what was what is
their original functionality of CRISPR
in nature and I'm curious bacterias
defense system yeah and we don't have
that we don't naturally have it I mean
kind of tab but there's there I mean you
could argue that there's crisper there
but that's how I mean that's where
CRISPR was originally from what the
scientific community recently discovered
was that we could be engineer CRISPR
with with our own configuration of an
input of what we want to identify so we
would we engineer CRISPR and in that
sense what we we found or an idea we had
from a very early stage was
that there have been some custom signs
described and found so cast iron cast
cast 12 cast 13 cast 14 but there are
many more custom enzymes within nature
to be discovered so the focus of of
identifying those has been mostly around
metagenomic data that has been published
so in NCBI or other databases so we we
focused on finding or processing
metagenomic data which was unpublished
and with within unpublished data we
focused on data from extreme
environments so so in that sense it's
not that we personally went but rather
we did partnership agreements of
exclusivity with research groups in in
Argentina in other countries of Latin
America from very precise location so
Antarctica than in volcano hot spring
very cool places obviously and and we we
just process their data from those
research groups that found no no value
within that data it was like I have that
data but I'm not using it for anything
I'm just maybe publishing some papers
and we processed it and I'm from there
applying our own criteria we found novel
or candidate novel crisper casts 9 cast
12 enzymes and that is an example of
what we found a novel cast 12 enzyme
which as you see is novel in the sense
that it has a very low percentage
identity when compared to any other
crisper cast and sign but has the key
catalytic amino acids which make it
functional and make it belong to a
cascode family for example that is
something that we found for now and also
we found the cast 9 but there's still
much more to be discovered in terms of
other variants of cast well cast 9 as
well as different systems which are
there in nature and which we haven't
found for now so Franco this really
excites me because one of the theses
that my colleagues and I have had for
some time now is that one reason to
preserve species diversity
is also to preserve the genomic and
genetic diversity of life that's evolved
because this very useful cast enzyme
evolved in conditions that are probably
difficult or impossible to replicate
yeah and so would you you know imagine
that there are many other valuable
enzymes of this class out there to be
discovered
yep definitely I mean there's there's
much more to be discovered and in that
sense when we were talking with these
first groups that wanted to join our
initiative they were like I mean they
were begging us please find something
here because if you find something I
will be able to convince local
authorities that there's value in this
place and preserving its nature rather
than just making it site open to tourism
or or building or mining or having
diverse commercial activities from that
region if you're able to show that
there's there's value in preserving this
nature and that we can help towards a
better world in our case to better
Diagnostics then I will be able to make
a statement and in that sense one of the
enzymes that we found was from one of
these places in Argentina and we're
presenting this information to local
authorities saying hey here you have
this is a big deal this this will help
the world Wow so this is this is a
positive example of bioprospecting in
action and that's really great that
you're you're reconnecting with the
local governments and showing them how
there's this value that many people
don't think about in fact most people
don't know about and as synthetic
biology or biological engineering or
whatever you want to call it grows as a
field we're going to discover more and
more of this value so that we we don't
want to lose it before we we can find it
and make use of it do you foresee Kasper
looking for more Cassadine or well more
cast analogs in general yeah I mean
that's that's an ongoing initiative in
terms of striking more more
with this kind of institutions and
you're financing our own searches within
within the region so cool and and and
yeah and also improving our criteria or
what things to to consider as candidate
crisper systems and they might not even
be crisper systems but just defense
systems from from a bacterial and
archaeal I mean there's there's a lot
more to be discovered when once you open
the scope of what you consider something
interesting and in that sense that's
something that we will be ramping up in
in the next month this is a great way to
put it is that when you look at the
timeline of like deep time of existence
there's so many things that we can still
identify that have occurred in the last
billions of years of evolution that can
give us unique insights into how to best
augment our health or how to best build
more sustainable futures just in general
for ourselves it's so cool that you can
go to these extreme environments and
find it and you just wonder how many
unique things are buried in our
archaeology of evolution that have been
undiscovered and how hard where do we go
to look for them how hard do we like
these search missions that you're
putting on for bio preservation and yeah
there's a that was yeah but it was
bioprospecting that's a cool cool word
yeah well and you know one important
element of that I think is that there is
a feedback to local communities so in
your case you are you know providing you
know reason for the local governments to
care about you know environmental
preservation and and now are thinking
about the potential value of
these these enzyme variants that you're
finding yeah also building upon that
tell me a bit about what types of
Diagnostics you're really excited about
your beachhead and especially how that
ties into Latin America hmm
and should we show the video yeah let's
do that let's see that's ok that's the
next slide the next is the video and so
this is what you're talking about with
Cass 12 it does a yeah that's like a
sense I'm a can sense I mean configure a
guide RNA which is complementary to the
DNA sequence of the target you want to
identify so the Casa enzyme we search
for the DNA sequence that the do was
configured for and if it finds it we cut
it and after doing this this is very
specific to cast 12 it will go crazy
start cutting indiscriminately so that
collateral activity we use by attaching
the reporter system which is after
Illumina quencher which are those who
have and as the class enzyme is cutting
and was cutting like crazy that system I
mean those will generate fluorescence
will generate an indication that the
target pathogen infectious disease or
genetic mutation was present in the
sample and this week configure it's kind
of a platform in the sense that you can
configure for any type of those targets
the input or the sample can be blood
saliva urine
the possibilities are our very best and
most excitingly this technology can be
configured or can be established in in
diverse formats so is is it's it's it's
it can be applied within labs so as a
lab develop test in its most elementary
form just on a reagent basis of these
three components the gas the guide and
the reporter system basically in what
what is a really disruptive format which
is in in a disposable point of care like
Diagnostics format so so doing
Diagnostics high-precision Diagnostics
stasis which it wasn't possible before
and CRISPR is enabling that that kind of
solution so so those ask the the main
formats in which this technology can be
integrated and consult precise problems
for diverse targets in each of those
fields and yes I mean our focus as
Casper is to do I mean what we see us as
the main value proposition or the
distinctive value proposition of this
technology is its accessibility
component so at a cost basis compared to
to PCR that has a strong advantage which
also takes longer yeah I mean within
that it kind of takes longer because
it's limited to two in lab diagnostics
so in lab driver yes comparing for in
lab Diagnostics the cost side which is
even more more pronouncing in developing
countries as everything has to be
imported and Wow the accessibility of
doing Diagnostics in places in which it
wasn't possible before so doing point
point of care Diagnostics with within
hospital rooms or directly and
pharmacies or direct to consumers for
specific targets in what would be a
lateral flow solution or a disposable
card solution and that is brought as a
possibility solely from from from the
properties and the simplicity that that
CRISPR has and what what was happening
at the very end there there's a
reporting system yes so so this is this
is with caste 12 specifically that
enzyme know the reporting system is is
like generally known from from the
scientific community
you bring the reporting system with yeah
I mean you you you you you input into
into the reaction or you pre-configured
this reporting system that has
fluorescence inhibited as a default and
once the class enzyme is cutting yeah
fluorescence is ignited
and that fluorescence that you get is
for a positive detection of the target
that you configure if the fluorescence
occurs if there is a positive direction
that's right
in the diagnostic yeah and so you can
you're adding you but you add a
reporting system into the Casa enzyme as
it goes to identify the certain segments
of DNA that's right and then it makes
the cut and then the reporting system
will fluoresce that's right if it's a
positive detection for if there's no
possibility tection there will be no cut
and there will be hence no persons and
also the amount of persons that you get
highly is highly correlated the amount
of with amount of target pathogen that
you had within the sample so in that
sense it not only detects but it also
quantifies whoa so yeah so barely any
brightness not too much of the disease a
lot of brightness you need to be treated
fast yeah and yeah and sheep also for
being able to ship into developing
countries all this type of stuff around
the world affordable faster yeah okay I
interesting and so how many other cool
discoveries like this are there yeah
yeah yeah so I mean what's exciting
about this is it's it's a really nice
platform technology and I think that
that platform technologies in general
are sometimes not are sometimes
undervalued early in their lifecycle
until everyone realizes that they're
useful give us some give us some
examples of what most excites you about
this platform going forward where
there's some proof of concepts that
really stood out in your mind when you
did these initial experiments and you
said to yourself the team said to itself
hey this is something we really need to
run with this is going to work yeah so
where were some of those moments or
applications yeah I mean there are
various cases in which we we see that on
a regular basis but a very interesting
example that what a personal level I
really enjoyed or said hey there's
something here we really have to make
this happen was in
in a pilot we did with a hospital in the
north of Argentina in Misiones which is
right next to to Brazil which is like a
tropical area so they suffered from
tropical virus season and then get
particularly and this is a lab that had
big hospicio equipment
but given the the the depreciation of
the currency and the cost in dollars of
importing PCR reagents they discontinued
the use of PCR so all of their
Diagnostics was based in the lab using
Aliza and in that sense when we came
with our pilot and showed them the lab
developed test format that of what they
could do within the lab and the cost
that that would have in the market they
are they were like very excited and when
we showed them the possibility which
arise of a validation that we did with a
lateral flow strip so no equipment no
need for a centralized lab just the tech
diagnostics at point of care in in less
than 30 minutes they they were thrilled
they almost started crying because this
would change a lot the the diagnostics
and the following of detection of
tropical viruses within the region to
another level and in that sense they
they put older their effort and their
samples and said we want to help you
guys doing this this is something that
can change the landscape for the region
and what how does this work so if you
bring Casper to this tropical region and
you want to help them detect dengue do
the diagnostic they take a blood or a
saliva sample yeah and then what do they
do with that and then what is your array
that yeah I'm very clear I mean we're
developing two two formats one I mean
and we already have results to show from
from that in
the format that we already developed one
is a ldt format which which alga Ichi ya
lab developed tests lab developed so so
this is just using the equipment that
they already have which is standard
within laboratories to measure for
fluorescence and instead of using PCR
mix so reagents for PCR which have to be
imported and which are already costly
they instead use the Casper CRISPR mix
so they would use our CRISPR mix within
those equipment ok and the work that was
in praia teri CRISPR mix yeah when you
deliver to these for this lab Devadas
yeah and that that is the the first
solution in which our go-to-market i
mean given the no regulation for for lab
develop tests and that you don't have to
do approval from FDA or equivalent
within those countries that's something
that in less than 12 months will enable
us to generate attraction and to already
start selling a solution for them and
then the second format which is kind of
the one that really changes the workflow
not only at a cost side but rather at an
an industry-wide
perspective is the the point of care so
so the lateral flow strip which is not
okay I have to extract that from this
patient take it to the central
laboratory where it will be running a
batch format and delays may happen and
train people are required and
electricity and all this this variables
which account for a higher cost but
rather is a direct from saliva or blood
input into this lateral flow so that
workflow kit kit and from there in less
than 30 minutes
if you get one indication it's positive
I mean based on the indication on the
mark which appears it's either positive
or negative and there's a
semi-quantitative component to that
where you can kind of more or less see
the the load of that
and and yeah I mean that is more it's
our time to market for that is a little
bit further or bit longer because you
you have to get that approved and for
now what we have of technologies is
capable of detecting for a single Plex
and that provides value for certain
contexts but the the best solution we
were able to push the limit of the
technology is a multiplex within this
kind of point of care Diagnostics and
that is what we want to bring to market
when when taking into account that
lateral flow solution no this really
excites me because I spent some time
thinking about multi drug-resistant
bacteria and all the different
resistance markers that one might
measure in those bacteria could be
easily measured I think my caspere's
technology because you're probing for
differences in the DNA yeah and you can
be very specific yeah so I can see you
know applications of your multiplex you
know cutting technology as it were in
you know antimicrobial resistance
mapping yeah and stewardship and so but
there's so many other other
possibilities I know that you're
interested in some functional genomics
applications of your platform and I was
wondering if you were going to maybe
tell us about a few of those yeah I mean
go going back to the first point of what
you mentioned with regards to antimicrob
assistance we we know of the relevance
of this phenomena and that is really
worrying for for the world in what what
what are the projections of estimated
deaths or the burden that this will have
over the world in the next 30 years by
2050 estimated that 10 million people
could die about antimicrobial resistant
related issues and in that sense we've
already done validations for them the
main antimicrobial resistance is such as
KBC and the EM Aqsa
and with we want to bring that kind of
solution to market it's it's a
complicated target as a whole in a
complicated area but it's definitely
something that we will be pursuing in
the next year's and in terms of
applications in more more broadly just
in functional genomics discovery for
caspere's platform do you have sort of
thoughts around that enzyme discovery
and yeah I mean that is what we were
talking previously that in in the sense
that we will be ramping up on our input
or our processing of data from from
these precise environments that we look
for and also it's a matter of of us
improving our criteria and that is what
enables us to to I mean it's not that we
just find custom science because it's
fun for us or it's cool to have new
custom science but rather because those
Casa enzymes can have key improvements
on specific variables of stability
performance specificity in the
Diagnostics application that we want to
take to market and also in other fields
in which maybe we reconfigure our search
towards those and things that have this
collateral activity or which are of
specific interest for us but the truth
is you never know what will be the end
functionality of something new that you
discover and in that sense the the
options of it being applicable for other
industries and other purposes beyond
including gene-editing but beyond just
generating are also very high and it's a
possibility of of what we see in what we
process and we're not the only company
that looking for for for this kind of or
has seen the value we've been finding or
trying to find this this kind of
knowledge systems and I think that it's
great that people go out there and try
the process with different criteria
and to find their their own novel
systems to to to use within specific
industries you know changing gears a
little bit you have a really you've had
a special experience in that you were
not initially trained as a scientist but
you're you're becoming one because have
become one and you've had a foot in both
the scientific startup world and
community in Latin America and now in
the u.s. yeah and I was curious you know
what do you how would you compare and
contrast those two environments and you
know what does Latin America do better
than us and what's easier here I'm just
curious what your experiences have
taught you yeah I mean I I'm really new
within Sciences that's the category but
most of what I got to know about
Argentina and Latin America as a
scientific community comes from the
experience of my co-founders one of them
Federico that has a trajectory of more
than 15 years within science in
Argentina Latin America and in that
sense there's like very interesting and
a positive side of the community and
there's obviously some disadvantages or
the downside of the region for example
with regards to to the downside there's
the the need for importing most of the
reagents and the time that it takes in
terms of waiting one can can wait 2 or 3
months for a reagent to arrive when you
compare with the timing here in the US
which is about two days into the less
than two days you can receive your
reagent that is crazy and for a start-up
that's even more crazy and even more
difficult that that is an example and
also the the changing currency and
depreciation of the local currency when
buying things from from abroad on
on the positive side you have this I
mean the funding for science at least in
Argentina from Coney said it's really
limited so scientists within the country
they have to find their way around those
limitations they don't have the luxury
of being capable of ordering everything
and having those arriving in two days or
in a week but rather have to be very
strategic about their pipeline of what
they want to do within the next six
months the next 12 months and in that
sense I feel and I see that there's this
this spirit of making things happen
beyond just the limitation of resources
and in that sense I mean it's a real
limitation of resources in the sense
that my co-founders could could do
research the budget for research for one
year could be less than ten thousand
dollars so so that's really difficult
and they told I mean that even more like
then going from those conditions and all
the expertise that they had from from
there and transferring that to being I
mean like painting the Campanile which
would be like playing in the best pitch
in the world and having to execute here
against maybe people that have graduated
from top universities in top
universities we we really work hard and
are able to to execute and to to prove
that there's there's very good resources
and knowledge with with in Latin America
with in Argentina on the science side
and and that being in the correct
conditions enabled us enables us to
achieve great things and that's what
I've seen from from my co-founders and
what also the indie bio team and a lot
of people which which followed us in in
the six months mentioned about us that
we we really performed fast and that's
not like a coincidence in the sense that
I would see my co-founders leave the lab
at 3:00 4:00 in the morning with some
frustrated with
it's about things that went wrong and
then waking up the next day at 7:00 in
the morning and I'm doing it all over
again so in that sense we were a good
team there's a lot of potentially from
Argentina from Latin America in the
science side and also I mean it's it's
it's knowledge and resources that are
capable of coping with this limitation
so our our product and our science
headquarters will all be in in Argentina
and and we we try to to leverage and to
to improve within the the local
scientific community and we find that
it's very strategic because there are
great resources and the average wage for
those kind of resources that we need
within our team can be up to 5x cheaper
than when you compare with with an
average salary here in the US for that
kind of position
so when during the program being here at
week two when we said okay we have to
hire a bioinformatics
which was like our first external hire
we search for people with here within
the US and I mean not to be rude but the
average salary which we saw was kind of
surprised at and was we kind of got
scared of oh this is this is very
expensive like this place for all of our
four salaries just by having this this
new person and there were interesting
profiles but no one that stood up and in
that sense we decided to to contact
people from Argentina
we got a reference from someone that we
didn't even know but was just the kind
of person that we need in terms of
commitment in terms of his previous
experience and we offered him to come
live with us for for the next 3-4 months
be a part of our team in during the
indie bio phase and that was like the
key hire of our team our only hire but
the key hire
and and he proved to be a great person
within the team which really adapt and
also for our future he's now a full-time
person with within the team and we we
lived in this house like the five of us
for the four months so so we almost
killed each other but then came along
and and became very very close friends
and team members so so in that sense
there's there's this two-sided part of
science within limited resources
countries and and science within the US
or other reference countries in the
world speaks to the network effect to
that the powers that gain the most at
the very beginning are likely to play
their own hand deal to themselves more
later on and figure out how exactly to
build moats around themselves to protect
others of their own resources but how
can that's such an important aspect of
what we care about talking about and
what we did our panel on is how to
figure out how to help bring the world
closer together with all these
opportunities and providing people an
abundance of options for them to figure
out what is the child's North Star how
can they go and pursue it themselves is
something that we care about so deeply
and that we want to help spread that
meme and spread those opportunities
around the world make it easier for
people to actualize and bring their
unique gifts to the world yeah that's a
big picture stuff yeah yeah yeah a loose
do you have another question that you
want to ask I have one other thing I
asked okay
just on the data side of things it just
seems like the future of where we're
going is me just having a constant
stream of my biometrics just input it
into a computer that's just processing
the stream of data and then just being
like a your you know stool sample or
your heart rate variability or we know X
Y Z whatever you're at risk for this
type of brain malfunction like you
should consider doing this exercise or
eating this way or sleeping a little bit
more bla bla bla
just like endless right this yeah so is
that what you see is like this future of
BI
attack I mean data we just keep on
reading us and it will be a lot around
health care and personal health care
oriented metrics it it it's for now it's
it's something good for us it might
reach 11 in which so much data at a
contact at a constant pace or at a
constant feed for us becomes too much
data and kind of becomes unproductive or
unhealthy for one owns mental health of
seeing a minute-by-minute basis how each
one's decision in terms of what you eat
or what what what you how you you cook
or whatever whatever you do in terms of
your body instantly yeah we yeah might a
fire might might affect your your your
your your your projected lifespan and
seeing how that increases or decreases
like in a minute basis obviously that's
that's very scary and and that would be
totally I mean I wouldn't like that
maybe some people would would like to
see that I would like to see how that
increases or decreases over time I think
that I mean that's something that we'll
see how how the industry evolves and how
is it that that information is
incorporated into the decision-making
process and obviously one sub has to
come the capability of deciding over its
own health and knowing that information
but also at some instances it's always
good to have the intermediate position
of a professional or a doctor that can
incorporate that information and deliver
to the patient on delicate subjects most
most importantly so so in that sense
that articulation or
or that means that we will also have to
to continue being there and it won't be
just all my information for myself but
there always has to be an uninformed or
a professional within for for some
indications or for some diseases and and
yeah it just seems like this is going to
be the part of this discovery plot
process so you know how are we going to
be discovering the right aspects of this
biotech archeology and applying it for
Diagnostics applying it for all
different aspects of our healthcare for
agriculture for all different types of
things it's just a very interesting part
of this biotech explosion that's
happening so of course yeah I mean at
least in the precision molecular
detection field this is something that
goes way beyond just health care
Diagnostics extends to an industrial
level to food safety to farming to
agriculture and those are all industries
in which there's already a detection or
Diagnostics component within them but
it's highly limited to two labs and in
that sense taking the detection to the
field can can really improve on those
industries in terms of the response or
the detection to to do pathogens to
punji to two different kinds of things
that that might pose a risk to a
population in general
and obviously responses to in terms of
biosecurity to bioterrorism or other
kinds of initiatives that there's
there's already some some really
important people within the industry
that are scared of how that might play
at a worldwide basis over the next 10 or
20 years and having access to rapid
adjustable adaptable detection systems
is something that we really have to push
and undeveloped as there will be a
timing which that will be a problem and
we we have to have some kind of response
prepared to that I'm ramming that it's
adjustable detection systems yeah yeah
yeah whoa
and I mean one thing that excites me too
is that these are semi-quantitative and
so that's that's really exciting too
so if you're thinking of looking at a
micro bio microbiota of something yeah
you know you could even do a
semi-quantitative census with saying
don't you multiplex product that you
might make so that's really exciting
because you know right now we often say
well you know species X is here it's not
here but it would be nice to know you
can begin to look at relative abundance
it's really exciting yeah yeah it's not
just yes or no on the diagnostic it's
also a quantitative amount of how much
that's in the future type date okay okay
just a couple quick questions some on
the way out are we in a simulation
that's kind I mean I don't know just
doing a question mark I don't want to
condition my my simulation yeah leave it
open
yeah for all the future possibilities
yeah and then what's the most beautiful
thing in the world
most the world mostly I mean I will take
it to a very biased this for me the most
beautiful thing in the world because I
was born in in Argentina and I'm a huge
fan of football which you call soccer
football
I heard you reference camp now yeah yeah
I mean and for me the most the most
beautiful thing in the world is La
Moneda Stadium in in in in Argentina
which is the soccer stadium of Boca
Juniors yeah for the stadium of which
team of Boca Juniors Boca Juniors yeah
interesting
that's I mean I yeah I kind of being
here in the US one of the things that I
missed the most was
going to the boca juniors stadium that's
all that that's why you might find in a
melancholy moment that's why yeah III
tend it towards a physical construction
as but it's a marvelous it's called the
temple for the people so it cuz it's
it's it's mystical component yeah
you played soccer yeah girl yeah me too
I love so much so much cool Wow
good stuff guys this has been awesome I
mean I had a lot of fun talking about
this with you thank you for coming on
front but thank you very much we're
really pretty sure it was great to have
the chance to speak to be part of
simulation and look forward to catching
up with you guys in some time with with
the updates of how we Casper us it's
evolving and doing yeah solving some of
the most pressing things around the
planet good job good job good thank you
very much thank you thank you for staff
Louis it's always nice to have you on as
well thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate you'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode revolutionising molecular
diagnosis talk more about this with your
friends families co-workers people
around the world on social media get
talking more about this next generation
of Diagnostics
and also check out the links in the bio
to Casper bio as well as check out
Franco's other profile links check out
bio captive a and Louis's other links as
well and also support the artists
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders the
organizations around the world do you
believe and support them help them grow
simulations links are in the Bible or a
patreon crypto-currency paypal our
design cool more should get paid link go
and support us thank you to around
vargas for producing and directing and
greatly appreciate it and go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world you love you very much
thanks for tuning and we'll see you soon
peace
you